do you
regret so she just look back would you
do it would you do any part of your life
different oh I'd scrap all this yeah
yeah um yeah I'd scrap all this to be
you know you always hear these guys say
I wouldn't change it because it made me
the man I am today the man I am today is
a 54y old scumbag multiple
felons starting my life over broke you
know living off of scraps you know
trying to make YouTube work like you
know I've
got you know two dead parents I'm
divorced I have a son that doesn't talk
to me I have a son that doesn't talk to
me for good reason not because of a
misunderstanding because he
understands like I he's you can't even
argue with him he's got a powerful
argument like I don't want to be a part
of this guy's life he's a scumbag he
stole money he went on the Run he
abandoned me when I was you know three
years old I don't want anything to do
with
him like
I I get it like I you know and I tried
to I tried to I've tried to do all the
right things you know I wrote the
letters I I I drew them pictures I've
tried to call and it's not happening
like I would do anything to go back and
just be that regular middle class guy
with the two kids and the wife working a
regular job you know I I like that's a
good life you know those are that's a
good person and you know
I I just made one arrogant decision
after another after another until it
snowballed and I couldn't take it back
and then I did everything I could and if
and if I
wasn't the
calculating backstabbing scumbag
that I can be I'd be in
prison right now so you
know so yeah yeah I would much rather be
a CPA right now I would much rather you
know should have stuck with being an
insurance adjuster or something I mean
you know I never should why did that
30-day L it out never it was a mistake
that was your first mistake that was a
huge mistake you think your son will
forgive you
no unfortunately according to my my
ex-wife and my sister and everybody that
he is a part of their lives you know and
I've seen him you know my mother's
funeral I saw him you know I I've seen
him at several functions you look across
and he
looks right through
me
uh I think that he's a everybody says
he's a he's just like you he's just like
you and everybody says I'm just like my
dad um I've never smoked a cigarette
I've never drank alcohol not a drop
never done any
drugs because my dad was an
alcoholic and my dad smoked two packs a
day and everything in our house rre of
nicotine and I've never smoked and my
dad was a a pill head he was he was
always on some kind of prescription
medication he was drug you know and I
didn't want to I don't want to I didn't
want to be that person and like one day
I drew a line in the sand and I wouldn't
do
it and I think he's drawn A Line in the
Sand and he's
decided you know this is the hill I'm
gonna die on and I'm I'm not gonna back
off it and and the thing is my ex-wife
tells him this he's a good person you
should be in his life his his father
because he was adopted when I was in
prison they adopted him uh Nick is his
uh you know his his dad uh Nick has told
him Nick came to see me when I was in
prison you know Nick has told him like
Hey you this this is a mistake you're
making a mistake Nick everybody that
knows me knows him and he said he has
said no so I fully believe it's no I
mean I hope it's not well I hope he
forgives you I think there's a lot of
good in you despite you calling yourself
as scumbag over and over in this podcast
that keeps bothering you you mentioned
that
earlier um what advice would you give to
young people given that you've lived
quite a non-standard life what advice
would you give them how to live a life
they can be proud
of I I
mean it's it's I'm in a position to that
anybody would listen to me but I I
because to me and I don't have any
advice that I don't think a father would
give you and it's like work hard be
appreciative I mean things are so good
out here I hear people complain all the
time and I think a huge part of just
being happy is being appreciative like I
didn't appreciate anything when I had
this is so cliche but when I had all the
money in the
world I was
miserable but when I got out with
nothing I was happier in prison with
nothing than I was with $2 or $3 million
prior to prison and driving dating a
chick I was never should have been
dating driving a sports car vacationing
all over the world
miserable I'm crying driving away from
prison because I already missed my
friends you you could have never told me
that was going to happen turns out money
in fact does not buy happiness no and I
know and it it is such a cliche right
but it's it's so true crying driving
away from prison yeah you know what um I
met my wife in the halfway
house so she had just gotten out of
prison she was in the halfway house with
me she just did five years for like a
meth conspiracy I never would have met
her if I didn't G to prison you know and
now you're uh date night is hunting
alligators together yeah we uh that was
that was that was like a month or so ago
this Florida folks this what this what
this is what badass people do in Florida
my my my wife hunting is a former she
used to so she was a milit an MP in the
military she was she did she hunted she
ran
a hog hunting tour guide service for six
years yeah went to prison for 5 years
got out and then you know now she's a
marine
mechanic and yeah our date night the
other night was uh we went in the middle
of the night went to uh Lake okachobee
and went hog I went to alligator hunting
yeah and if I may say so she's quite
beautiful so thank you I I did I did
nice she didn't want to date me in the
halfway house too I kept saying I feel
like you're sweet on me she's like I'm
not yeah I'm not I I make fun of guys
like you you're a city boy I'm like I
don't know I feel like well you wore her
down I that's that's just what exactly
what I did yeah it's that Charisma it
always works well Matt thank you for for
being so honest thank you for being who
you are I do think there's a lot of good
in you and thank you for telling your
story and the story of others who have
uh whove made mistakes in their life
thank you for talking today I appreciate
you having me on that was a really short
conversation